this
is lbc from global leading britain's
conversation
with ian payne
good evening it's ian payne sitting in
for tom salbrick who's sitting in for
breakfast
all this week now a coalition of some of
the world's wealthiest people have
signed an open letter urging governments
to tax them
more to pay for the coronavirus crisis
i will repeat that they have asked
governments to tax them more heavily
to pay for the coronavirus some 83
millionaires
from the us uk germany new zealand
canada and the netherlands
signed a letter organized by
millionaires for humanity let me read
you a crucial quote
to our fellow global citizens they write
as coven 19 strikes the world
millionaires like us have a critical
role to play in healing the world
no we are not the ones caring for the
sick and intensive care wards
we are not driving the ambulances that
will bring the ill to hospitals
we are not restocking grocery store
shelves or delivering food door-to-door
but we do have money
lots of it money that is desperately
needed now and will continue to be
needed in the years ahead
as our worlds recover from this crisis
today
we the undersigned millionaires ask our
governments to raise taxes on people
like us immediately
substantially permanently we thought
this was a very
interesting story one of the 83 is
a man called gary stevenson he's an
economist he used to work in the city
as a trader and he retired at the age of
having become a multi-millionaire gary
is one of four
british millionaires who've added their
name to the group i rang him earlier
tonight
started by asking him where the idea for
this letter came from
this letter originates in the u.s from a
group called
patriotic millionaires obviously you can
probably tell i'm not from the us
i'm uh from london i live in london i
was connected by a group called tax
justice uk
so um i've been basically looking around
the area
of a tax reform ever since i quit the
city a few years ago
and i've been attached to this
organization tax justice uk
i did a big article in the garden a
couple of months ago saying how i think
there's going to be a lot of inequality
resulting from coronavirus and the best
way to fix it will be
a wealth tax and uh that organization
got in touch with tax justice uk he put
him in touch with me
why will a wealth tax in your opinion
help various economies
so i think the big problem that we're
going to have in this economy
going forward well there's a couple of
things the first thing is
we need to get spending in the economy
and i think it's going to be very
difficult to get that
if the ordinary workers are struggling
and i think we're going to see that
definitely going forward this furlough
scheme ends
this month in terms of the first time
companies have to make payments
a lot of people are going to lose their
jobs at the same time
we can see lots of data that high income
people have accumulated a lot of money
during this crisis
but if confidence is low the chances are
that money is going to be
saved it's going to be put into assets
like housing like stocks
we've already seen stocks go up hugely
i've gone up about
40 or 50 percent in the last few months
i'm expecting to see how they've got
more
if that's the situation that we're in
then a lot of ordinary working people
which are the
driving force of the economy and the
people we need spending are going to be
struggling
so if we don't find some way to get
demand and spending power
from the richest in our society i think
we're going to really struggle to get
out this crisis
i'm a bit confused you say stocks have
gone up 30
40 percent every index i look at it sort
of fluctuates every day
it's certainly down since since march
where where are those stocks that are so
wonderful coming from
yeah the uk market is still pretty much
down since pre-covered levels
if you look at the u.s market they're
already
above the levels i think at the turn of
the year some of the tech spots such as
the nasdaq are flying
i personally invested in gold and gold
is up
hugely um yeah they're still down on
pre-crisis levels but uh
i trade in the 2008 crisis and at this
stage in that crisis
stocks are enormously done we've seen a
phenomenal bounce back
since the bottoming of the stock market
much faster than anything we saw in 2008
and uh i'm predicting that will go up a
lot more
very quickly even in spite of a week
economy and that's a result of the huge
amount of money printing that's
happening at the bank of england
do you believe that every rich person
say in the uk would agree with you
and would like to be taxed more
i think it's very very unlikely to be
honest uh
you know i'm sure you find a lot of
opposition so
your your view is that if if if the
wealthiest get taxed
then that will be distributed is that is
that trickle-down economics what is that
called
uh well you could call it demand-side
economics i mean i think
absolutely talk a little bit about the
economic situation as it has been since
2008. okay
interest rates have been zero in this
country
pretty much every country almost
constantly since 2008
and the reason that that has happened is
because the central banks
are desperately trying to get people
spending and it's just failed year after
year after year
and uh most economists expected that
these very low interest rates get people
spending
but it hasn't happened and my belief the
reason why that hasn't happened
is because most of that money is ending
up going to very rich people
who don't tend to spend extra money they
get
and uh you know i don't come from a rich
background i was
poor now i'm not poor i know people
all through the spectrum rich people
don't spend
money when it's given to me in the same
way that what no people do
so if inequality increases you're going
to struggle
to get demand and get customer spending
i'm fascinated by your story i read that
guardian article that you were referring
to i mean
the very first line caught my attention
i made my first
million the year greece went under i was
24 years old at the time
you were basically betting on gloom were
you
yeah yeah pretty much yeah so i started
working in the
in the city at 2008 so obviously how old
are you
so how was i then did you say yeah uh in
2008 i was 21 when i first started
okay and uh obviously that was when the
crisis happened
and uh really my job was to predict
interest rates so
just a quick explanation the central
bank pushes interest rates down when
they think the economy is weak and they
want people to spend
and they bring interest rates up when
they think the economy is hot they want
people to save
so in 2008 interest rates collapsed
massively
hugely so previously they would move
rates like four and a quarter to four
and a half
here they fell from five and a half all
the way to zero and everyone expected
we'd see a big surge in spending
so everyone predicted in 2009 we'd have
a recovery it didn't happen
in 2009 everyone predicted it would be
2010 that didn't happen
in 2010 it was it would be 2011. and by
then i started to become suspicious and
started to really question these ideas
of why
is the spending not happening what do we
need to do to get the spending happening
and uh we had this big meeting with the
senior guys at the bank where they
explained basically the financial
situation of all of the governments in
europe u.s japan most of the major
governments in the world
big deficits big debts i mean that's
very reminiscent of the situation now
and uh i couldn't help but realize you
know
people i knew back home in a similar
situation
they're running losses month to month
and they've got debts
if the governments are in debt and the
people are in debt it can only mean
there's a small group of people
who have a huge amount and if you need
to get the economy spending which is
what central banks have been trying to
do now for
12 years you can only get that spending
from the rich
so uh i bet that because i couldn't see
inequality improving
i went back and i bet that this is not a
temporary crisis a permanent crisis and
um
that's what i believe so you so we could
all come become millionaires if we bet
on interest rates
staying low because this economic
situation is as bad as i can remember in
my lifetime
well that's a good question you would
have been able to do that in 2009
2010 2011 2012 13 14 15
16 17 or even the beginning of this year
you would have made loads of money
better management
oh no unfortunately at the moment pretty
much everyone in the world
thinks interest rates will be low
forever which is not a great
sign for the future of the economy i
mean we can look now at for example the
interest rate you would get
on 30-year bonds at the moment
what interesting do you think you'll get
on a 30-year uk bond
oh don't ask me for goodness sake gary
i've no idea it's uh
just over half of one percent which
basically means they think rates will
stay zero for the next
20 to 30 years so that is the realistic
situation so i've been saying
for the last 12 years rates will be zero
forever we're not going to come out of
this crisis unless we address inequality
and uh finally the world's come around
to my point of view
which is probably not a great thing
unfortunately
what's when you say you you multi
millionaires want to be taxed more i
mean what sort of percentage rate are we
talking about
as i remember in the 70s you know people
moving overseas because
here they were being taxed i mean i
think heath was taxing people over 90
percent who earned as much as you
so for me the big thing here is and i'd
like to point out
the different signatures on this letter
will have different opinions for me and
my background in economics what i think
the big thing is we need to start
looking at ways to tax wealth
rather than just income because at the
moment we have a situation where the
richest in society
are able to pay very very low taxes
because they don't get their income from
work like the rest of us do yeah and the
current tax system is not really set
up to tax very well this non-work income
yeah so you end up with a situation
where you know i made a lot of money but
i paid 50
on that and i'm comfortable now but i'm
a lot less rich than you know some of
these barons of westminster who
are billionaires and have paid nothing
so we really need to develop a tax
system that taxes
this accumulated wealth of the very rich
personally i don't want to be going
after doctors and
lawyers and radio presenters i'd rather
be going for the
very very wealthy and to be honest i
think if you don't do that
i think we're going to be in a very very
bad situation okay and the question i've
always want to ask somebody with a lot
of money is what do you do all day
you've retired uh at the moment i
i write articles trying to explain to
people the importance of wealth and
equality i've actually
been putting a video together this uh
last week and that will go off my
youtube garry's economics
tonight okay that's explaining how the
coronavirus is increasing inequality
we're going to the cash flows very
simply
just to explain that so uh yeah i'm
working on videos i'm working on ways of
spreading this message
that wealth inequality is very damaging
to the economy
um i don't need to do that i don't get
paid too much to do that but the truth
is
i make my money by betting on what's
going to happen i've done very very well
i think i'm a good economist
i think i know what's happening here i
think that unless you fix inequality
things are going to be really really bad
for my family
my friends for all the new working
people in this country
so uh yeah i'm coming on radio shows
like this and uh
trying to spread the word so that was
economist gary stevenson speaking to me
earlier one of 83 very wealthy people
who formed a group called millionaires
for humanity
calling for themselves another super